ideas are banging around in your head
all the time and you keep pushing them
away and until some get more insistent
and that's exactly what have to with Mad
Max this idea popped into my head it was
five women being chased across the
wasteland pursued by a warlord and Max
gets caught up in their story and I said
to myself no way I don't want to do
another Mad Max movie but like all good
stories they really do insist on being
made in some way it's got winning in in
the indigenous Australian culture one of
the creation stories is the story of
Seven Sisters escaping some malignant
male and they help create the topography
and all the nature around and there's
only enough that I figured out we're
telling that story the only reason it's
five Brides that are being chased by the
warlord is that we couldn't fit seven
into the car the champion had to be a
warrior and if it was a male it just
wouldn't work it would be one mass
dealing by wives of another man it had
to be a female warrior and hence furiosa
the very first person who came to mind
and sure leads she was furious she
walked out of the makeup then and roll
around in the dust just to get it under
under and nails and before we started
the film she said look I've got to tell
you something I hate to dust on my head
she has some sort of aversion to it also
we have wipes and things he said no no
it's gonna help me she was the one who
said look I'd really like her to have no
hair if he was serious she wouldn't mess
around in here in the wasteland with all
the dust and so on and the other things
you was determined to do with not do any
action as if it were a female doing a
man's job you see the way she does think
that head but at the end of the movie
difficult to pull off and she was
scarily good in there one of the great
concerns about the film is whether
people could read enough to get the
story
we were never explicit about everything
we knew something happened and so in
this race to get to the Citadel she is
the one in far
self in the position please the closest
to immortan he's very badly wounded and
she uses this moment to hook this
happens on his mouth and so remember me
implies a lot of grievance about their
backstory we can speculate as to what it
might be but we don't know all the
details
I remember show these on that they said
look I feel like I really want to save
the life okay no you I said write it
just hear this week's mark and it was a
little pause before the brutality of the
moment and the continuation of the
action that was to come where an actor
really is in that zone you fool not to
listen the way I like to measure the
work and still is so how long does it
follow you out of the cinema if you
forgot that by the time you're in the
carpark then that's just not such a good
movie the greatest films and the ones
that stay with you for a lifetime
I didn't expect fury road to be so well
received there's a tough film to make
but I've had people come to me and say
I'm just having a newborn baby girl and
I'm gonna name her Furioso when I come
up and show me their tattoos of the
characters in the film on the mother oh
my god they're gonna be carrying that
around for the rest of their lives
literally that's the best compliment I
could get it's a humbling thing because
it says that you have a big
responsibility as the storyteller you
can't be casual about your story
there are narratives that becomes part
of people's lives